there are still plenty of free agents
out there chris and we're gonna have
some fun this segment because there are
actually three guys currently available
who were number one overall picks in the
draft i have never researched this i've
never even thought about it but the idea
that that you could have guys who were
drafted in the last decade
three of them
three of them number one overall who are
all available at the same time again
that that may be unprecedented it's
genavian clowning jameis winston and cam
newton and we're going to try to uh to
figure out a landing spot for each of
those guys i haven't let you talk for a
while here we go i like this that's okay
it's all right you like the talk
i do like to talk and i like this
graphic that was put together with gene
rayburn the match game was awesome the
thin microphone the the uh the the not
so subtle innuendo that would work its
way into some of the questions and some
of the answers you know brian billick
was a
contestant on match game back in the day
with an awesome leather jacket uh you
can find that on youtube but don't find
it can we watch us well yeah don't find
it now but can we get some new pictures
of our faces like i want to update on me
okay that's like four years old and
that's my evil roger goodell picture
that you make fun of all right my
haircut is different that's a different
thing oh it's a different one you're
right either way i want that change and
i definitely want yours changed you're
not that young and good looking anymore
i want something more realistic
something within the last decade that
looks like it's eight to ten years ago i
need i want more more wrinkles and more
gray in your hair now i like that
picture better
you are such an ass
yes i am and that is rude
that is rude you are rude you are a rude
human being
yes i know i work with a rude human
being so it's wearing off on me
uh hey look i mean wait you know what
chris if you live another 15 years
you'll be 54 too at some point get ready
for it it's coming it's gonna happen to
all of us and you can only hope that
you're fortunate enough to make it this
far uh and uh uh you know so let's see
how much farther i can make it beyond
this because you may defy the
stay-at-home order and drive down here
and and uh and kick my butt if i don't
shut up i'd like to all right yeah
here's what we're gonna do three
categories for each of the three number
one overall picks who are available
front runner dark horse and fantasy
choice and let's start with davey and
clowny the first overall pick in 2014
who is your front runner for jadavian
county services
i i think the i would look at the
seattle seahawks as still being the
front runner you know first off because
of the covet 19 situation right i think
it's going to be hard to get your
deviant county to a medical doctor that
a team is going to feel comfortable with
he is a guy that needs a full
examination he's coming off a sports
journey surgery we've talked about the
knee seattle knows what he is i don't
think he's going to get a really
long-term contract out there in free
agency because of these injury concerns
i think he'll be offered a lot of one
and two-year deals and i think because
of that i think seattle knows who he is
he knows seattle he knows they're going
to be a team that's in the race here as
far as coming out of the nfc with
russell wilson so i'm going to go with
the front runners being judeo i mean
seattle seahawks i agree with you
completely that they know who he is they
were with him all year and uh i i assume
well they always do an exit physical at
the end of the season so they got to
look at him before he had sports hernia
surgery and they may have had an
opportunity to take a look at him before
the facility shut down he became a free
agent they had exclusive rights to him
until he became a free agent last week
so i i think the seahawks make the most
sense i just think they're waiting for
clowney to come to the realization that
the pot of gold is not going to be out
there for him elsewhere
yeah no i think that's exactly it and
you know it's just it's an unfortunate
year for gene davion claudi you know for
him to be a free agent and have all this
going down in our society certainly not
helping his cause as far as uh
capitalizing on all his money all right
what's the next one we're going with
dark horse dark horse what's your dark
horse for clowney i'm gonna go the
philadelphia eagles okay i just feel
like uh they they were kind of in the
conversation for it last year you know i
do think they could use another edge
pass rusher on their defense that's what
made them special when they went to the
super bowl they could send waves of
defense alignment at you you know they
got a little bit money left still to
spend as far as cap they've been proved
their defensive line with javon hargrave
i think that was a great signing on the
inside but i think you know that'd be a
team where i'd like to see him end up at
and i think it makes some sense scheme
sense and i think there's probably some
interest there in philadelphia if they
can get them at the right price
and i'm going to say the miami dolphins
for mine there have been some reports
that the dolphins expressed some
interest in jadav and clowney i really
do sense that even as they try to
rebuild they are attracted to plenty of
unrestricted free agents they signed 10
from other teams last week and maybe
once clowney accepts the fact that he's
not going to get what he wants
he takes less from a team other than the
seahawks just because he's myth the
seahawks aren't giving him that big
contract he thought he earned last year
and even though he was injured and
that's the knock on him he can flip it
around and say i busted my butt for you
guys last year i played through this
injury and this is the appreciation
you're showing no i'm going to go
somewhere else if the market's not going
to bear what i want i'll take less from
another team and i'll go to the dolphins
yeah i mean i you might be right and
they could probably throw some stupid
money out at him to outbid everybody
else uh i i think he he again would fit
with what brian flores wants to do on
the defensive side of the ball that
hybrid 3-4
defense where clowney can be a defensive
end he could be a stand-up outside
linebacker if you wanted to use him that
way too he can do a little bit of
everything uh so you know i'm with you i
don't think that's a crazy thought at
all
all right fantasy option and this can be
anything you want just where you would
love to see him line up what uniform
you'd love to see him wear
well
okay i guess if you're gonna make me
choose any right now i mean this is not
really realistic but
i i think there's a part of me that like
to see him join the kansas city chiefs
and improve that defense but the kansas
city's got no room on the on
you know in their cap space they're kind
of uh hamstrung there so i say that i'd
love to see that but like okay should i
go more realistic a more team that i
feel like i'd love to see him go back to
houston okay houston could afford him i
think that would be funny right now to
see him go back there they could
certainly use it they need that type of
player they lost dj reader jj watts
getting a year older whitney merciless
is good but not great anymore so i think
in realistic where i'd like to see him
go and have fun with i'm going to say
the houston texans
see and i'm going to stay in the same
state because i want to put any of these
guys with the cowboys because i want the
cowboys to be as interesting as possible
and genevieve and clowny would make them
interesting but also the tampa bay
buccaneers and i know they've got jpp
and they've got shaq barrett but hey
one of the reasons the eagles would want
him they'd love to have that rotation of
six to eight guys add him to the
rotation if you could keep him fresh and
if you could keep him healthy and he
whenever he's on the field he's going to
be racking up those f up the play
statistics that you love so much that's
how he would be the most dangerous not
out there all the time put him in a
rotation of eight guys put him in tampa
bay now good luck paying him but uh
that's the fantasy option for me either
dallas or tampa bay all right let's move
on to jameis winston speaking at tampa
bay who's your front runner for the 2015
number one overall pick in the draft
uh i'm i'm still gonna stick with my
pittsburgh steelers thought you know i
have no idea where jameis winston ends
up to me again we've talked about this a
lot you know pittsburgh's got a really
good football team we saw when they lost
big ben roethlisberger that you know
their offense fell apart you know that
wouldn't happen if you had jameis
winston and i think it's a great like
jameis winston's the kind of guy that
you know you take a shot on he could end
up being your future after big ben
bothers burger retire or something like
that but i would be scared if i'm the
steelers to risk ben getting hurt again
and now let's having to play this
defensive style we have to invent some
type of offense to be competitive and
win games 13 to 10 man that's just hard
to play that way so i'm going to stay
with uh the steelers in that combo
and i'm staying with the saints and i
know that sean payton said yesterday
that taysom hill is gonna be the backup
to drew brees this year he'll be number
two i think that just may be part of the
posturing to try to get the price to go
down for whoever they may be eyeballing
and i think it makes a ton of sense to
have jameis winston as the game day
short-term back-up because you're gonna
have completely different offense for
taysom hill and they could whip it
together quickly i guess if they had to
but it worked last year having teddy
bridgewater ready to run the base
offense you got 11 other guys or 10
other guys on the field to think about
if you start changing the offense
dramatically you have a quarterback who
can run that same offense that's what
jameis winston should want to do and and
look
it there is no frontrunner because no
one's interested this is the only
category where front for our answer
should be no one
i don't know it's the craziest thing and
listen i have people around the nfl who
have texted me like
have you heard anything on jameis
winston and i i go no it's crickets i've
never seen anything like it i've not
heard one rumor from anybody i trust or
anybody i know that knows anything that
has a feel for where jameis winston
could end up so i mean i'm clueless i
know we're we're just taking shots in
the dark right now
who's your dark horse candidate for
jameis winston i didn't intend to this
happen and i'm not going to say that i
overly prepared for this segment okay
all right i i did not because for some
reason i didn't realize we were doing
all this i must have misread our rundown
a little bit i didn't intend to do this
but i'm going to eagles
transparency is good but you have to
balance the trend there's a limit to the
transparency
okay i live this crap okay and i got a
good idea anyway so just deal with it
all right this is all i do all day i'm
gonna sit in my kitchen and watch
football the whole freaking day so i'm
not gonna be that far off base even
though i didn't get to think about it a
lot at 11 o'clock last night all right
you like that better so shut up and
listen to everybody but i'm gonna go to
philadelphia eagles again i i didn't
mean to do this but i go i mean carson
wentz has an injury history are we
really gonna put it in nate sudfeld's
hands
that philadelphia eagles you know i just
i wouldn't do that i don't trust that i
haven't seen enough from nate sudville
than any preseason action to where i go
ah when he takes over they'll be in good
shape no problem you know it's just
risky and we've seen carson wentz he can
get banged up i think that's another
spot where i would think about jameis
winston he could come in and run that
offense has a similar skill set to
carson wins i'd go with the new england
patriots i mean brian hoyer stidham the
longer that bill belichick is looking at
that is his depth chart and he reminds
himself 5 109 passing yards for jameis
winston last year i mean if anybody can
break jameis winston out of the what the
hell were you just doing mindset it's
going to be bill belichick and josh
mcdaniel so that's attractive to me
fantasy option for jameis winston
49ers i i i mean if my buddy kyle
shanahan was listening to me i'd go kyle
take a shot on jameis winston why not i
mean jimmy garoppolo he slips up next
year you know shanahan has a way of
making life very easy on the
quarterbacks where it's just like hey
look at this guy if this guy goes this
way throw it to that guy if he goes that
way throw it to this guy and and i think
james that to me would be jameis winston
good deep ball thrower i'm gonna say
that would be my fantasy
you took mine you took mine yeah
i was thinking the same thing having him
behind jimmy garoppolo so i'll go with
the rams i'll say the rams they don't
have a backup right now i think they had
blake bortles under contract put him
behind jared goff and maybe sean mcveigh
can fix him and maybe at some point sean
mcvay realizes hey you know what winston
may be a better quarterback than jared
goff that's a it's a good one i think
that's another team that should think
about it you know again what you don't
want your team to fall apart you know
too many of these teams have backup
quarterbacks where they go oh he's good
in the meeting room he can get us out of
the huddle yeah but he ain't gonna get
he'll get you losses too that's great
that he can draw a nice little circle
and x on the on the chalkboard damn
let's give him another three million
dollars how about let's see if he can
win games and i like play at a high
level on the field to me too many teams
dropped the ball with their backup
quarterback with that nonsense all right
we got one more let's rip through it
quickly cam newton who's your front
runner
chargers chargers come on la chargers
that's what i want to see i mean that's
to me that's yeah it just makes too much
sense uh so i'll make it quick that's it
yeah me too and we've been talking about
that i've been talking about the
chargers
as the prime candidate for cam newton
ever since philip rivers had his seven
interceptions in back-to-back prime time
games all right who's your dark horse
for cam newton i i you know mike i think
the thing you taught said yesterday is
ring's true to me i'm going with the
miami dolphins i do i think that makes
you know i don't think it's crazy you
know at the miami dolphins maybe they
were set on tua and then they don't like
what they see from tua and they don't
trust that now they can't maybe have a
medical examiner all over them and all
those things and maybe they go oh man
you know what we're not really loving
any of these quarterbacks in the draft
this year man cam newton's not a bad
fallback option you could stumble into
your guy being the the franchise
quarterback for the next five years
yes he turns 31 later this year he could
be around for a long time all right i'll
go same thing dolphins now that i
convinced you that they are a viable
player who's your fantasy option for
newton new england i mean i think if i
just had to have fun
i would love to see cam newton and bill
you know bill belichick and josh
mcdaniels have to like orchestrate some
new offense and play with cam newton
it'd be really cool i don't think that's
really realistic like i've always said i
think they love jared stidham and they
should but i mean we're having fun here
and i think that would be a lot of fun
to see
hey and cam newton is 2-0 all time
against the new england patriots if you
haven't heard no i you know i heard that
from someone before i'm not sure who i
heard that uh
my fantasy option is one that we were
spitballing yesterday yeah radiesse why
wouldn't the raiders be interested in
cam newton i mean think about it yeah
they they were
at least considering tom brady
they've got marcus mariota as a backup i
i'm sorry and you know people think i i
personally dislike derek carr i just
think that he's not as good as people
think they are he's not a top half of
the nfl quarterback i think cam newton
if healthy is clearly better than derek
carr why wouldn't your old coach john
ruden want cam newton chris
yeah well i mean i hear you mike i mean
yeah a healthy but it's just a big risk
that's that's what it is right now and
we just don't know and that i think
that's the biggest thing and i don't
know if they know really what they
totally have in derek carr yet i think
this is the year where they're going to
have enough talent around them they're
going to say it's your third year in the
offense and you know it's put up or shut
up time this year for derek carr i don't
think he'll have any excuses you know
last year he played well but it wasn't
great and he didn't have great talent
around him so that will be used as a oh
we don't know what he really has quite
yet type of excuse for them or anybody
else that's questioning it so i think
that's probably the big reason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports